Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is about creating high-quality
physics simulations and is, in my opinion,
one of the gems very few people know about.
In these physical simulations, we have objects
that undergo a lot of tormenting, for instance
they have to endure all kinds of deformations,
rotations, and of course, being pushed around.
A subset of these simulation techniques requires
us to be able to look at these deformations
and forget about anything they do other than
the rotational part.
Don’t push it, don’t squish it, just take
Here, the full deformation transform is shown
with red, and extracted rotational part is
shown by the green indicators here.
This problem is not particularly hard and
has been studied for decades, so we have excellent
solutions to this, for instance, techniques
that we refer to as polar decomposition, singular
value decomposition, and more.
By the way, in our earlier project together
with the Activision Blizzard company, we also
used the singular value decomposition to compute
the scattering of light within our skin and
other translucent materials.
I’ve put a link in the video description,
make sure to have a look!
Okay, so if a bunch of techniques already
exist to perform this, why do we need to invent
anything here?
Why make a video about something that has
been solved many decades ago?
Well, here’s why: we don’t have anything
yet that is criterion one, robust, which means
that it works perfectly all the time.
Even a slight inaccuracy is going to make
an object implode our simulations, so we better
get something that is robust.
And, since these physical simulations are
typically implemented on the graphics card,
criterion two, we need something that is well
suited for that, and is as simple as possible.
It turns out, none of the existing techniques
check both of these two boxes.
If you start reading the paper, you will see
a derivation of this new solution, a mathematical
proof that it is true and works all the time.
And then, as an application, it shows fun
physical simulations that utilize this technique.
You can see here that these simulations are
stable, no objects are imploding, although
this extremely drunk dragon is showing a formidable
attempt at doing that.
Ouch.
All the contortions and movements are modeled
really well over a long time frame, and the
original shape of the dragon can be recovered
without any significant numerical errors.
Finally, it also compares the source code
for a previous method, and, the new method.
As you see, there is a vast difference in
terms of complexity that favors the new method.
It is short, does not involve a lot of branching
decisions and is therefore an excellent candidate
to run on state of the art graphics cards.
What I really like in this paper is that it
does not present something and claims that
“well, this seems to work”.
It first starts out with a crystal clear problem
statement that is impossible to misunderstand.
Then, the first part of the a paper is pure
mathematics, proves the validity of a new
technique, and then, drops it into a physical
simulation, showing that it is indeed what
we were looking for.
And finally, a super simple piece of source
code is provided so anyone can use it almost
immediately.
This is one of the purest computer graphics
papers out there I’ve seen in a while.
Make sure to have a look in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!